parce sanitaires et son expansion en
vigueur dès lundi on continue d'en
parler avec nos invités rhône est chiche
il est historien et professeur de
philosophie et denis millet co président
départemental de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france rené chiche
quatrième samedi de mobilisation on peut
dire qu'on assiste là à un mouvement qui
prend de l'ampleur
oui j'avais pu permettez-moi le prenez
pas mal mais vous avez annoncé des
réalisations à l'appel de furieux six
diplômés en réalité il n'ya pas de porte
parole de ce mouvement qui est un
mouvement spontané d'indignation d'une
très grande partie de la population
parce que les mesures qui nous sont
présentés comme des mesures sanitaires
sont en réalité des mesures extrêmement
violente et je dirais même plus perdre
et as lorsque l'on est dans un état où
le consentement à la loi suppose la
capacité pour le site rien de
reconnaître le bien fondé de la loi et
que l'on utilise la loi pour le faire
agir contre son consentement contre son
jugement contre son intime conviction
on a affaire à une violence morale
violences psychologiques et moi je
comprends tout à fait les réactions non
seulement des personnes qui manifestent
mais il y en a aussi beaucoup qui
manifestent pas et qui sont complètement
épuré et je tiens à préciser qu'il y en
a beaucoup y compris parmi des personnes
qui sont vaccinées
parce que on essaye de transformer le
débat actuel concernant le pass and it
est rôle un débat sur la vaccination ce
n'est même s'il ya des points communs ce
n'est pas du tout le même sujet en
réalité on a bien vu que le pass
sanitaire doit sur le pass sanitaire qui
est d'ailleurs très mal nommé puisque en
réalité celui par impasse c'est un
laissez passer
c'est un passeport n'a rien de salutaire
le gouvernement est le premier à le
reconnaître
j'ai quitté il n'y a pas très longtemps
le ministre chargé des transports
expliqué devant une question qui est
quand même
gênante comment se fait-il que l'on
impose un passani terre pour le tgv
qu'on n'impose pas pour le rer ou le
métro et il a répondu d'une façon très
claire que l'objet de cette loi n'était
pas du tout n'était pas du tout
sanitaire que en réalité le l'objet la
visée sanitaire elle était réalisée par
le protocole qui était mis en place dans
tous les transports à savoir le port du
masque etc etc
mais le but de cette fois c'est
simplement de forcer les gens à se faire
vacciner et on aura certainement
l'occasion d'en débattre avec mon
interlocuteur mais il n'y a absolument
aucune raison
si la loi je répète si la loi n'oblige
pas les individus les citoyens à se
faire vacciner si par conséquent la
vaccination est reconnu par la loi comme
un acte libre et librement consentie et
bien il n'y a aucune raison de procéder
de la sorte c'est à dire finalement
d'utiliser des méthodes absolument
abominable déloyale de chantage de
menaces voire même de mise au ban de la
société et pourront obtenir quelque
chose que la loi les deux mandats donnés
mais est ce que vous comprenez ces
milliers de français un 2 pièces 4
samedi qui sont dans la rue et qui
refusent l'idée d'un pass à nanterre
c'est compréhensible ça donne cette
impression qu'on comptera un peu le bras
pour viger à vacciner en même temps le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu aller jusqu à
l'obligation vaccinale donc il essaie
par ces moyens de le faire mais je pense
qu'il faut reconnaître que la
vaccination elle est d'abord efficace et
surtout ça qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il
faut noter c'est efficace donc il faut
le faire après la manière dont le
gouvernement si si si essayé essayé de
faire passer ce message allez peut-être
pas toujours efficace et c'est pour ça
qu'on a cessé réaction je pense que les
anomalies les petites imperfections de
communication qui a eu au début sur les
masques et tout ça on est un peu le
discrédit sur la communication de nos
gouvernants et c'est ça qui je pense un
peu irrité effet que beaucoup de gens
sont dans la rue pour ce à quoi
rené chiche on a différentes personnes à
ces manifestations à des personnes de
tout âge d'horizons différents vous
l'avez dit des vaccinés des non vaccinés
que nous apprend la composition des
cortèges sur la mobilisation qu'on est
en train de toucher à défilement à des
fondements à la fois au niveau de l'état
de droit au niveau de la république
parce que hull loi qui procède par la
ruse et une loi que on ne peut pas
admettre contre les républicains
là je pense qu'il ya dans la rue
beaucoup de gens qui manifestent pas
forcément contre telle ou telle mesure
particulière et notamment la vaccination
et je reviendrai sur ce qu'a dit mon
interlocuteur sur l'efficacité de la
vaccination mais qui manifestent aussi
parce que on est en train de toucher à
du sacré je veux dire quand on en est au
point d'interdire l'accès aux hôpitaux
et aux établissements de soins à des
personnes qui ne sont pas en capacité de
montrer un passeport vaccinale j'oserais
même je tiens à rappeler qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont de sérieuses
raisons de ne pas se vacciner que ce
soit des contre indications médicales
que ce soit parce que la vaccination
c'est un acte médical qui doit
normalement se prendre avec mesure avec
précaution et dans avec le conseil de
son propre médecin et il ya énormément
de médecins qui considèrent que la
balance bénéfice risque n'est pas du
tout en faveur de la vaccination pour un
tas de gens donc ces gens là ont de très
sérieuses raisons de le refuser et
j'aimerais dire puisque mon
interlocuteur a parlé de l'efficacité de
la vaccination peut ce n'est pas le
problème le problème ce n'est pas celui
de la vaccination
le problème c'est celui de la stratégie
vaccinale du gouvernement le
gouvernement contre même la vie de l'om
s estime qu' il faut vacciner la
majorité de la population pour parvenir
à réduire la circulation du virus est
effectivement tout le monde le sait on
peut être vaccinés est porteur du virus
qui fait qu'avec le pass and it erp vous
allez permettre à des gens qui sont
vaccinées de pénétrer dans des lieux
l'on veut je prends l'exemple encore une
fois de l'hôpital que l'on veut être des
lieux zéro co vide alors que la seule
manière finalement de faire de ces lieux
des lieux hero call it ce serait de
tester et pas de tester avec un test de
vieux de 48 heures mais de tester avec
un texte vieux de douze heures de six
heures parce que sinon c'est pas sérieux
en fait on est je pense que les gens qui
manifestent sont des personnes très
intelligentes et qui sont capables de
comprendre qu on les roule dans la
farine qui ne veulent pas se laisser
faire
donnez amis vous êtes pharmacien vous
avez dû certainement rencontré des
français qui est refusée à un idée du
passani terre pourquoi selon vous il
s'en méfie est ce que ce n'est pas parce
que le gouvernement n'a pas assez
communiqué autour de ce vaccin anti
corrida je pense qu'il ya un déficit de
communication c'est que c'est clair par
contre je reviens sur ce que dit mon
interlocuteur le vaccin efficace on le
sait ils protègent les vagues les
vacciner peuvent diffuser mais de
manière extrêmement faible par rapport à
mon vacciner kiko qui contractent le
virus
de même l'idée de faire un test
immédiatement on a on sait que les tests
peuvent être négatif alors que le parc
face à un porteur de l'ordre de 10 à 12
10 à 15%
donc on exaltante même phénomène sur on
sait que le vaccin est efficace
on sait qu'ils protègent on sait qu'ils
empêchent de diffuser de manière assez
basses y vit encore une étude qui vous
entendu parler d'études ce matin encore
qui disait la même chose donc je pense
que ça c'est une évidence il faut il
faut il faut pas la nier maintenant le
fait que le gouvernement ait voulu
passer de manière un petit peu là l'iran
d'où c'est un peu ça en disant on va
vous obliger à le faire parce que si
vous voulez vivre normalement il faut
que vous ayez votre pas salutaire c'est
vrai que c'est ça qui peut provoquer la
colère et ça je peux la comprendre
par contre on a un phénomène où on a eu
déjà deux ou trois agressions pharmacie
en tendant pendant ces on a eu des
agressions pharmacie pendant les
manifestations l'incompréhensible je
pense qu'il faut appeler au calme les
gens qui sont dans la rue le pharmacien
il fait son travail et les contacts
qu'ils vaccinent pas ce que ça se crée
sa conviction qu'il faut le faire
il fait des tests il est là pour la
santé publique qui à part aucune raison
d'attaquer une pharmacie où je voulais
attirer l'attention sur ce point là
parce que c'est vraiment très grave rené
chis vous le désert du gouvernement a
annoncé si vous vouliez dire quelque
chose peut-être oui
évidemment on peut que condamner les
agressions mais il faut il faut quand
même pas oublier qu'il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes
on n'a pas évidemment les chiffres
exacts enfin il ya énormément de
personnes qui défilent et on va pas à
chaque fois refaire le refaire le coup
de montrer tant d'heures en boucle
pendant des heures et des heures tel
incident telle agression pour jeter le
discrédit sur sur un mouvement qui
encore une fois n'est pas un mouvement à
l'appel de telle ou telle personnalité
politique c'est un mouvement spontané
d'indignation et je pense que hélas ça
ne suffira pas parce que nous avons en
face de nous un gouvernement qui a de
toute façon décidé d'aller jusqu'au bout
et qui veut passer en force il l'a
montré il a obtenu du législateur dé
rendre compte des concessions qui sont
absolument ahurissante parce que le
législateur a avalé des couleuvres
je redonne les données en train de
parler de quoi là on n'est pas en train
de parler simplement du restaurant en du
cinéma on a quand même des personnes qui
sont privées de l'accès aux soins
c'est extrêmement grave on a des
personnes qui sont menacés de perdre
leur travail si elle ne consentent pas
se faire vacciner alors que au moment où
elles se font vacciner on leur demande
de signer un document qui dit qu' elles
ont la possibilité de le refuser
par conséquent on joue sur les deux
tableaux je suis désolé mais là c'est
exactement
c'est une méthode très connu pour rendre
les autres données mais y est vous
parliez un de l'efficacité des vaccins
c'est vrai qu'on a encore du mal à
appréhender cette efficacité
on a peut-être parfois l'impression
qu'on entend des choses différentes
l'entente est différente parce que selon
selon la conviction de la personne qui
la diffuse on n'a pas la même le même
son de cloche mepha les études
scientifiques et sont là les études qui
a eu horreur en israël il ya eu en
angleterre qui sont des pays les plus
laxistes et sont flagrants les gens qui
sont qui le contractent le virus et qui
sont hospitalisés sont majoritairement
des gens non vaccinés et les chiffres ce
qu'on veut mais les chiffres quand les
analyses scientifiquement il nous
bien que la vaccination protège que la
vaccination empêche d'être hospitalisé
que la vaccination empêche d'être en
réanimation et ça c'est majeur sans
compter le fait que ça que ça évite de
la continuation de ses proches parce que
même si on est porteur je le redis on
est quand même beaucoup moins diffuseurs
de virus que les charges virales ou des
vaccinés sont beaucoup plus faibles que
ça donne envie que ces messieurs merci
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france riche historien et professeur de
philosophie et denis millet co président
départemental de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
merci à vous monsieur d'avoir été en
direct avec